- I can't drink green tea,
but I can put the tea bags on my eyes.
(upbeat music)
(sobbing)
- I drink some form of caffeine every day.
- I'm pretty aware of how
I can't function without caffeine.
So this is it, this is my last one.
- I guess the only time
that I don't have caffeine
in my system is when I'm sleeping.
- I've been drinking
coffee since I was seven.
- I was asked by my doctor
to stop drinking coffee.
That was a few months ago, and I have not.
- I just want to know that I can do this,
and the world will continue to spin.
I'm making it through my
first day pretty okay.
I'm not super exhausted,
I don't have crazy bags under my eyes.
- Typically I'll get a
coffee on the way to work.
Today I get nothing.
(sobs)
If I don't drink coffee, I feel tired.
I just came home for lunch,
A little sad.
because I don't feel like
I can be around people.
I'm pretty useless as a
person without caffeine.
- It's the second day and I'm
dead already, look at this.
- You kinda can't quit something
unless you actually want to quit it.
- I want coffee.
- More irritated that
I can't have something
versus the fact that I'm
not drinking caffeine.
- So it's day three or four,
I can't be sure anymore.
- I'm definitely eating more.
- Literally my best friend this week.
- 11:15 and I'm driving,
and I don't feel safe,
if I'm being honest.
- I'm about to hit that.
- Do I seem weird to you?
- Yeah, you seem dumb. (laughs)
- I've been super
irritable this entire week,
and I'm so mad and I'm so on edge,
and every little thing irritates me.
- I think my biggest
challenge throughout this
was just finding things
that I could drink.
I was given this tumeric tonic.
It tastes kind of like curry water.
- It's Monday morning,
feeling hopeful that I'm
not gonna drink coffee.
- I could barely think
sometimes at the end of the day.
Part of me was just missing.
Definitely excited for no coffee,
for coffee, I can't think, I can't think.
I don't want to say I
didn't have a purpose.
I've just been doing a
lot of internal screaming.
- I still have a headache.
I really thought this would be easier.
I couldn't go a day without Advil.
It's crazy how big a
role it plays in my life.
- I know that I function as
a shadow of a human being
without coffee, but I didn't
realize how deep it was.
- What's been cool about
this whole experience
is that I've learned that I definitely
don't need caffeine for energy.
- I am way more addicted to
coffee than I even realized.
I forgot, I forgot, and I made it,
it was instinctual, and it's delicious.
- I stuck to it, I did it.
- I can confidently say I can go a week
without touching any bit of caffeine.
- I got over the headaches,
I got over the fatigue
and the irritability.
- I got back so I don't feel
like a complete failure.
- If you ever feel like you
are addicted to something
or are controlled by something,
you should definitely
try to take a step back
and see if you really are.
- I, as a person, don't want
to be dependent on anything.
If you really want to
stop doing something,
then think about it just
hour to hour, day by day.
- I'm glad I did this, but I love caffeine
and I'm not sorry about it.
I'm having green tea and it's amazing.
I missed it so much.
This is the greatest thing ever.